Julie's in Sacramento hi Julie how are
you I'm bad as I deserve but how can I
help today well I'm working on my desk
snowball and I own my own business and I
owe one of my staff members back pay and
I'm trying to figure out where to pull
that money do I reduce my owner's draw
so that the money is coming directly out
of the business or do I continue taking
my full owner why do you why have you
not paid your employees I only have one
and it's my mother and it was her idea I
lost over fifty percent of my income
this year and so she said while you're
getting back to clients and such go
ahead and not pay me and we'll keep
track of it yuck yeah I hate it I
absolutely hate that I haven't paid her
so how much do you our about 2,100 okay
and what is the income of the business
in a given month
um it's ranging around 21 to 2,500 so
you're not making any money not right
now I was making more but I've taken a
lot of hard hits this year one clients
left you know they moved out of town
they couldn't afford me anymore just you
know various life changes of theirs and
I didn't get the usual new client till I
get each fall in spring wonder why I
don't know it might be a lean year I'm
not quite sure what if I decide I just
going to show up my finances and work on
my debt until for the moment yeah what
do you do I'm a dog walker okay and why
do you need an employee on it's only
$100 a month business um originally I
was doing all of these clients myself
and that was like five tips walks a day
which was physically too much for me to
do I was gonna have
to give up a lot of them so when we did
this I was making enough to business
cuts in half you don't not pay your
employees you lay them off okay until
you get your business back going again
because the business right now is very
manageable by you what and so she's
sitting around doing nothing right I got
my special needs client in like two
others which you could handle true
because you don't have any business
right now
yes now I am also earning money lifts
driving which is what I'm doing in the
off time yeah i if she wants to help you
for free
mm-hmm at this stage that's fine but I
don't want you building up debt to your
mother anymore and you don't make it you
don't make enough in this business to
pay an employee
I'm not accruing to anymore I've managed
to turn it around enough that I am
keeping up on it so you're paying her
now yeah you don't make enough in this
business to pay an employee okay if your
total gross revenues are $2,000 a month
you don't make enough to have an
employee okay and so you've got to let
your employee off yeah yeah that's awful
but I mean really cuz you know it is and
then you know she's just on the list of
people you got to pay when you start
making a little money again and you get
the business built back up and just say
you know mom if I can get the business
built back up and you want to come back
I'd love to have you back but right now
I don't have enough business to justify
having an employee okay and you're gonna
have you know you don't have a choice
because think about if you hadn't if
this hadn't occurred this way let's say
you started from scratch zero clients
and then one client and then two clients
and then three clients and you got the
business up to twenty one hundred
dollars at this point you wouldn't go
hire an employee
because you don't make enough to pay one
at $2,100 a month you wouldn't go hire
an employee would you I did you didn't
do it at 2100 you did it when you had a
lot more clients okay so that's what I'm
saying
you you the fact that it's come back
down me you know the way that you got
into the situation caused you to not
address it you would never have done it
in Reverse so anyway you either need to
get your number of clients up
dramatically in the next 30 days or mom
needs to take a little time off and you
need to take care of your own clients
and then work your way back up hold on
I'm gonna send you a copy of Christie
Wright's book business boutique and I
equipping women to make money doing what
they love it helps ladies start running
grow businesses and it'll help you a
bunch with this hold on I'm gonna send
you a copy as my gift hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]